lui n'a pas eu besoin de traverser
l'atlantique pour rejoindre le festival
de cannes puisqu'il vit dans le sud de
la france
l'américain johnny depp a mis le feu à
la croisette aujourd'hui lors de la
présentation de pirates des caraïbes 4
films projetés hors compétition et dans
lequel apparaît aussi une jeune
française astrid bergès en portage
sabine gorny olivier tu y es tu
aujourd'hui la croisette avait hissé la
grand voile mégastar à bâbord et un
raz-de-marée de fans de chasseurs
d'autographes pour le plus sexy des
pirates le moulinette et au chapeau vous
cette taxe par ce serait peut-être mieux
avec un capitaine
une île et classe quoi et puis moi suis
dessus donc ça me suffit quoi suis venu
pour lui j'ai passé assez vite
on n'a pas trop si elle il aurait pu
marcher un peu plus lentement et poser
un peu plus quand même mais bon c'était
sympa quand même d'après la rumeur cher
très cher capitaine sparrow qui a
rapporté en trois volets de la saga près
de 3 millions de dollars aux studios
avec un personnage de rebelles déjanté
auquel il s'est depuis ses sens
totalement identifié le sparrow c'est un
mélange de rock r2 xviiie siècle inspiré
par keith richards est une sorte de bon
à rien d'aujourd'hui j'adore encore bien
entouré notre joli coeur entre ont goûté
latine et vénéneuse au tempérament de
feu traîner nos frais cruz mutinerie
capitaine ultime et jolie sirène
française de 25 ans qui n'en revient pas
de nager en eau trouble auprès de six
gros poisson les sirènes du film sont
beaucoup plus inspiré des vieilles
légendes des des histoires de l'odyssée
d'homère par exemple et du coup il y
avait quelque chose à à trouver et enfin
servir toujours pas en fait l'ex fis
avec tout avec ce casting incroyable et
ces gens très talentueux
ce soir là bel ashton avait retrouvé ses
jambes pour fouler sapri rouge avec
johnny et compagnie une parenthèse
glamour et enchanté qui a exalté notre
pirate préféré